bessie olive sally and jess have one
big thing in common
they all
love
jazz
[Music]
this is live oak florida a small town
west of jacksonville
not the type of place you associate with
jazz
and yet
there's ed
i'm a dairy farmer here in north florida
home to about 6 800 cows
that it
he can really blow
he's been playing trombone since
elementary school
but his audience has changed
this is his story
the first time i can remember the cows
coming up is i was just standing on the
backyard and playing a trombone and
all the cows came up to the fence i had
a full audience
they're not particularly critical either
cows are very much creatures of habit
the music is something that's out of the
norm and that's why they're entertained
the cows have a an ability to understand
what's threatening and what's pleasing
and music is definitely pleasing to them
i have no idea if it's the one heifer
heard the music and the rest of them are
following the other heifer but it really
doesn't matter at the end of the day
we're all having a good time
my dad told me when we were kids he said
it's important from day one how we take
care of animals we like to consider
ourselves good stewards of the land good
stewards of the animals playing the
trombone is not any different than going
out and how we feed our cows and we take
care of our cows it's all about our
interaction with these animals our
animals they care and so you play music
to them they will remember that
[Music]
you